[موسيقى]
اعتماد روسيا على الجنيه المصري وادرجه من
ضمن العملات المعترف بها في
المركزي الروسي يمكن بيقلل الضغط على
الدولار او احتياج الدولار في مصر يمكن
الفتره الاخيره احنا شفنا ازمه شحح العمله
الصعبه وازمه الدولار في مصر
وبيقلل من فاتوره الواردات يمكن احنا
فاتوره الولادات مع روسيا بتقدر بحوالي
4.8 مليار دولار وردات من روسيا تتمثل في
الاغذيه همم القمح والحديد
[موسيقى]
بالتاكيد طبعا يمكن اعتماد الشركاء
التجاريين يمكن من اهم الشركات التجاريين
دول الصيني يمكن من اكثر الدول اللي مصر
تستورد منها برده هي الصين في اعتقاد ان
في لو تم
ادراج الجنيه المصري في المركز الصيني او
من قبل الصين طبعا هيخفض الضغط بشكل كبير
جدا على الدولار واحتياج الدولار كعمله او
الجنيه المصري عمله تبادل ما بين مصر
والصين بالتاكيد طبعا هيخلي ان في حاله من
حالات الاستقرار